märz 20 21 mehr als anderthalb jahre
liegt hubert grätz jetzt im wachkoma
niemand weiß was er noch mitbekommt aber
aufwachen wird er wohl nie wieder
seit wenigen wochen kann er ohne dicke
kanüle im hals atmen
sein sohn hat dafür gesorgt dass sie
entfernt wurde rückblick im august 2009
10 verliert hubert grätz die kontrolle
über seinen wagen das auto überschlägt
sich der rentner erleidet schwerste
verletzungen an schädel hirn und
rückenmark noch am unfallort öffnen die
rettungskräfte die luftröhre des
70-jährigen vorschriftsmäßig doch der
fingerdicke plastikschlauch eine
sogenannte travian kanüle wird auch
anderthalb jahre später noch immer in
seinem hals stecken auch dann noch wenn
es dafür längst keinen medizinischen
grund mehr gibt
die familie von hubert grätz anders
nicht als sie nach dem unfall für den
vater einen intensivpflegedienst sucht
der patienten mit beatmungs kanäle
versorgt es fällt dem sohn schwer
darüber zu reden er bittet uns in so
wenig wie möglich zu zeigen
die familie soll ein wg zimmer für den
vater direkt beim pflegedienst mieten
680 euro 80 für 34 quadratmeter dazu
kommt der pflegevertrag mit der
krankenkasse über 14.000 euro im monat
man hat ja immer gesagt wenn er das tut
man nicht hat dann muss er halt da raus
weil dann kann man ihnen nicht mehr so
abrechnen
und wenn wir dann gefragt haben kann man
den augen und eilt dann auch selber
bezahlen
diese ist amazon hält das so viel geld
haben sie nicht kaum eine leistung
bringt pflegediensten so viel geld ein
wie die häusliche versorgung von
beatmungspatienten der sohn fürchtet
jedoch die kanüle könnte seinem vater
sinnlos schmerzen bereiten
das ist gar nicht so schlimm
das spüren anderthalb jahre geht das so
dann überwiegen die zweifel an der
beatmung wg der sohn verlegt seinen
vater in ein ganz normales altenheim bei
ihm holt sich die familie eine zweite
meinung und seine ärztliche diagnose
steht schnell fest
atmung und schlug reflexe funktionieren
in der luftröhre des vaters steckte eine
trial kanäle die keinen sinn machte
jedenfalls medizinisch nicht das heißt
ich habe hier einfach nur mal einen
patienten sehr eindeutig erwischt
sozusagen der mit einer
behandlungsmaßnahmen die qualvoll ist
über lange zeit behandelt wird ohne dass
irgendjemand die indikation überprüft
und es geht einfach nur um ablegen der
zeit und ich sage es ganz offen um ein
sehr sehr gutes geschäftsmodell
gruseliger kann es nicht sein
das geschäftsmodell beatmungs wg
funktioniert so der pflegedienst tritt
formell als vermieter auf der zimmer an
patienten untervermietet nur so ist es
häusliche pflege und kann bei den kassen
auch teurer abgerechnet werden
pro patient bis zu 30.000 euro im monat
stationär sind es nur 6500 frontal21 und
korrektiv treffen einen krankenpfleger
er arbeitet in nordrhein westfalen in
zwei anderen beatmungs wgs mit insgesamt
20 patienten er erzählt wg patienten
würden möglichst krank gehalten damit
man sie maximal abrechnen kann
mittlerweile habe er gekündigt und will
deshalb nicht erkannt werden das ziel
ist es alle möglichen leistungen von den
krankenkassen maximal auszuschöpfen das
wird regelrecht geplant und man kann
einen patienten länger krank halten als
er ist
weil immer mehr beatmungs wgs auf dem
markt auftauchten gebe es um die
patienten ein hauen und stechen sagt er
nur leider nicht immer mit dem ziel den
menschen wieder auf die beine zu helfen
theoretisch wird die kanüle natürlich
von einem arzt geprüft und verordnet
aber ärzte kooperieren mit
pflegediensten da gibt es ein geben und
ein nehmen die kaltschnäuzigkeit beruht
darauf dass die patienten sich nicht
wehren können im fall von hubert grätz
belegen behandlungsunterlagen neben
seinem sohn zweifelte auch eine
logopädin an der notwendigkeit der
drachen kanüle in ihrem therapie bericht
vermerkte sie das dringlichst abgeklärt
werden solle ob eine degradierung also
entfernung möglich sein
der hinweis führte jedoch nicht dazu
dass die kanüle beim vater entfernt
wurde
der pflegedienst zeit auf nachfrage
schriftlich mit zitat intensiv
pflegerische maßnahmen verordnet allein
der arzt und weiter heißt es damit ist
auch die unterstellung obsolet eine
behandlung erfolge abrechnungsbedingt in
den behandlungs dokumenten von robert
krebs findet sich kein hinweis darauf
dass die kanüle überprüft wurde
trotz der dringenden empfehlung der
logopädin sein sohn erzählt der arzt der
seinen vater in der beatmungs wg
betreute habe ihm empfohlen
wirtschaftlich zu denken
die trafikanten am unfallort sei ein
glücksfall gewesen
wir fragen nach beim arzt der schreibt
zitat diese äußerungen wurden von mir
nicht getätigt unsere frage weshalb er
trotz anraten der logopäden die kanüle
nicht überprüft habe lässt der arzt
unbeantwortet der pflegedienst der in
nordrhein westfalen seine mutter
behandelte gehört inzwischen einem us
amerikanischen investmentfonds
mein eindruck war einfach dass es nur um
den wirtschaftlichen teil halt ging
meine mutter war eine geldquelle seine
mutter agnes kartmann war auf künstliche
beatmung angewiesen 2018 starb sie an
der lungenerkrankung copd monate vor
ihrem tod brachte der sohn seine mutter
für zehn tage in einer beatmungs wg
unter bei einem besuch findet er sie mit
einem auf fast 60 prozent abgesagten
sauerstoffgehalt vorerst auf sein
drängen hin sei der notarzt gerufen
worden
meine mutter lief blau an und man sagte
mir halt ja das hatte heute morgen schon
mal gehabt das geht gleich wieder so und
meine mutter rüttelte und ich dachte in
dem moment blockt meine mutter stirbt
hallo esslingers ich größe sehen eine
sprachnachricht vom pflegedienst als
patrick slickers seine mutter aus der
beatmungs wg verlegen will habe man
versucht druck auszuüben
wir sind ja eingesprungen um ihnen zu
helfen oder vielmehr ihrer mutter zu
helfen dass sie adäquat versorgt wird
natürlich ist mit dieser hilfe für uns
auch ein wirtschaftlicher faktor
verbunden
eine entlassung adhoc wäre für uns jetzt
katastrophal weil wir natürlich auch
kapazitäten in der wg aufgestockt haben
aber wenn sie so entscheiden würden wäre
das so versuchte der pflegedienst
todkranke patientin aus wirtschaftlichen
gründen in der beatmungs wg zu halten
der pflegedienst widerspricht zitat
selbstverständlich respektieren wir es
wenn unsere bewohner in eine andere
einrichtung wechseln wollen dass andere
motive etwa wirtschaftliche rein
spielten weisen wir zurück
der pflegedienst erklärt außerdem seien
alle erforderlichen notfallmaßnahmen
sofort eingeleitet worden
die staatsanwaltschaft sah keinen
hinreichenden tatverdacht experten gehen
davon aus dass 70 prozent der patienten
in beatmungs wgs langfristig keine
tahrir kanüle benötigen
trotzdem steigen die zahlen
während im jahr 2005 noch 1000 patienten
zu hause mit beatmungs kanüle versorgt
wurden
10 2009/10 allein die gesetzlichen
krankenkassen schon 19.100
leistungsfälle in häuslicher umgebung
mit medizinischem fortschritt allein ist
dieser anstieg nicht zu erklären der
bundestag hat inzwischen ein gesetz
beschlossen
es soll die fehlanreize bei der
häuslichen beatmung beseitigen es gelten
aber jahre lange übergangsfristen für
palliativmedizin schönstes ist dennoch
ein wichtiges signal dass es jetzt ein
gesetz gibt das man zumindest monatlich
die indikation also die notwendigkeit
dieser beatmung überprüfen muss und man
fast sicher natürlich an den kopf dass
das nicht längst schon so ist zurück zu
robert krebs der konnte ohne kanäle
leben
trotzdem steckte sie in seinem hals
anderthalb jahre lang patientin einer
beatmungs wg perspektive wenn er da
geblieben wäre wäre so gewesen dass er
über die nächsten jahre da einfach
weiter gepflegt worden wäre
ich kann ich ihnen auch sagen dass mein
vater so was nie im leben wollte
inzwischen ist sein vater gestorben
seine letzten atemzüge aber durfte
hubert grätz eigenständig machen ohne
qualvolle beatmungs kanäle
[Musik]